[Evans] Here's the answer.
When the procedure starts, p refers to some list that was passed in.
We want the procedure to work on any list,
so we shouldn't assume anything about the list that was passed in.
It could be any length.
And i has the value of 0.
That means the value of p index i is this first element of the list p.
In the loop body we print out that element,
and then we go on to the next element by increasing i by 1.
i will now have the value 1.
We go to the next element of p.
We're going to keep on going until we get through the elements.
What we need for the test condition of the while
is to figure out when to stop.
We learned about the len operator.
The len of a list tells us the number of elements in the list.
The highest index in the list is not the value of len
because the list starts from 0.
The highest index is the value of len(p) - 1.
So we want the test condition of the loop to make sure
that i has not exceeded that last index.
We could write that condition many different ways.
One way would be to use i < = len(p) - 1
since we know i is an integer since we created i, initialized it to the value 0,
and the only thing we do with i is add 1 to it.
This is equivalent to a simpler expression: i < len(p).
Either of these would work as the test condition for our loop.
We'll use the shorter one since it's simpler.